sogar um die ecke wie gewesen hat immer
gesagt und abruzzen nicht vergessen und
meint das müsse man die auch immer sagen
im gegensatz zu der er verbal
inkontinent ist kommt es bei mir noch am
richtigen lochs heißt das dass beim
texten die meisten texte von ihm sind
oder wie funktioniert die zusammenarbeit
da er so ich würde jetzt zum beispiel
sagen bei dem titel zunge weg der mir
wirklich einen mittleren brechreiz
verursacht hat was auch glaube ich
beabsichtigt ist der bestand aus seiner
feder zone weg oder ich muss 14 hat er
komplett gedacht und handelt von einer
von einem liebesakt mit durchfall bei
dieser text ist tatsächlich von 2 sowie
die meisten texte die wir machen die
dann ein bisschen die richtung geht wie
sind und andere bei denen man es nicht
erwartet
die vielleicht sehr ernst sind er dann
von mir sind okay es gibt ja hier einen
titel an
ich würde mal sagen der zielt ein wenig
dicker hat heißt er
der zählt ja ein bisschen auf das web
ist ich würde sogar sagen wenn ich hier
genau bewerber barbara was blieben
deutsche rapper sind arm
ja genau warte mal war genau mein text
ist als lösungs vienna oder wartet ein
flug auf als ihr vorbild und dann gibt's
irgendeine schrift oder toccata sogar
die türkischen backpfeife na ja das wort
zuviel chase liefert geschmackvollsten
ducatis lieber greifen genau dann jedoch
schon haftbefehl erklärt ich wollte
jetzt passt auf wo ist es wo es ab und
wo ist es forschung gibt es überhaupt
eine grenze sagt selber die verstehen
gar nicht zum teil wo die ironie anfängt
und wo es echt ist oder ist das echte
schon ironie also in meiner noch kurzen
auseinandersetzung mit dem genre hip hop
habe ich vor allem eins gelernt dass
nicht nur die oper selbst sondern auch
ihre fans sehr humorlos sind okay und
dass sie sehr viel austeilen aber ganz
wenig nur einstecken können und dass ein
bisschen auf die spitze zu treiben und
zu sagen bleibt mal locker wir machen
euch nun nach das war auch unser
anliegen aber wir haben auch durchaus
ernste seiten in dem album wo es nicht
nur darum geht sondern die brille
liebesleben ja wo es um kindermord zum
beispiel auch geht auch mit speed aber
eben mit einem tragischen ende und das
war das was wir auch besonders fanden
dass wir gesagt haben wir sind keiner
linie verpflichtet keinem image dass
irgendein verlag uns ausdrückt sondern
wir sind wir wir machen das worauf er
bock haben und das ist sehr
unterschiedlich
musik bleibt ist und war immer schon
geschmackssache
und das wird sich nicht ändern ich kann
niemandem eine musik zurechtlegen die
ihm passt
was nicht nur ärgert ist dass es eine
industrie gibt die versucht das zu
machen und sie macht es auf eine sehr
geschickte art und weise so dass leute
auch darauf reinfallen
also nehmen wir mal beispielsweise rtl
mal mein lieblingsthema lieblingssender
früher haben die plattenfirmen sich die
arroganz geleistet zu sagen wir
entscheiden im stillen kämmerlein wen
wir zum star machen und nicht und die
motive und die faktoren nachdem sie
stars erkoren haben waren
markttechnische motive also welcher
junge hast in das bild der bravo leserin
den wir jetzt zum star machen können das
hatte mit musik wenig zu tun
irgendwann kam rtl dazu weiß was wir
machen das vor den augen der zuschauer
wir beteiligen die an diesem prozess wir
zeigen denen sogar wie dieser
untalentierte dämliche sackt plötzlich
zum superstar gemacht wird in dem ein
bisschen schminkt aufs gesicht bekommen
und plötzlich hoppelt wie ein pop
bisschen und die leute was haben sie
gemacht die haben nicht gesagt die zeigt
uns dass ihr uns verarscht und dass die
industrie so perfide ist auch noch geld
zu verdienen dass sie es uns zeigt so
die leute abgekauft mark medlock ist auf
platz eins gegangen
diese straßen striche aus offenbach der
resozialisierungsmaßnahmen ist ich
plötzlich deutschlands größter superstar
geworden warum weil rtl die macht hatte
mit seiner quote die leute zur kasse zu
treiben inklusive aller seiner neben
medien und den leuten zu suggerieren das
ist ein star
das ist etwas was mich erst